es sind schock sekunden für ein
dreijähriges mädchen und alle menschen
die dabei waren beim internationalen
kite festival in taiwan verheddert sich
die kleine im schwanz eines großen
drachen der sofort von einer bö in die
höhe getrieben wird meter hoch wird das
dreijährige mädchen brutal mitgerissen
es dauert 30 sekunden die sich für alle
anwesenden gespült haben wie stunden bis
der drache wieder so niedrig fliegt das
augenzeugen das kleine mädchen
festhalten und befreien können wie durch
ein wunder geht es ihr gut bis auf ein
paar kleine kratzer bleibt sie
unverletzt
dennoch wurde das festival kurz danach
aufgelöst